[Música]
yo siempre pensado que conocer la
realidad del salvador no siempre es
totalmente fácil a mi me bastaron 75
centavos para hacerlo si yo les
preguntara que representa 75 centavos
para ustedes probablemente me podrían
decir que representan los pasajes del
bus que es para comprar unos dulces lo
que es una cantidad insignificante de
dinero yo un día conocí a carlita una
niña que había en san vicente y me
contaba como con orgullo había utilizado
la primera ganancia de su emprendimiento
de dulces artesanales para poder apoyar
a su familia un día llegó su mamá y le
dijo hoy nos vamos a comer no tengo
dinero ni comida
carrie está en ese momento tenía 13 años
y yo me preguntaba qué hace una niña de
13 años cuando su mamá le pregunta y le
dice esto probablemente aguantarse al
hambre dormir
esperar o quedarse de brazos cruzados
pero perlita tuvo una actitud diferente
y precisamente les dijo ahí tengo unos
centavitos vayan a comprar comida esos
75 centavos sirvieron para que la
familia de perlita conformada por seis
personas pudieran alimentarse esa noche
compraron que esos huevos y tortillas
otra de las veces que hablaba con
carlita me comentaba como todos los días
también a 30 minutos para ir a traer
agua al río para toda su familia yo me
imaginaba que iba a ser un río super
grande pero la realidad es que cuando la
compañía del río el río era éste cuando
yo conozco historias como la de carlita
llegaba y cuando iba camino a mi casa
cuando llegaba siempre llegaba con un
mix de sentimientos tenía impotencia
pero también tenía esperanza por un lado
tenía impotencia por mí porque me daba
cuenta que estaba siendo parte de esta
generación que yo denomino los eternos
desagradecidos de la vida esas personas
que nos quejamos por todo pero no
hacemos nada de repente nos quejamos
porque no nos gusta lo que vamos a comer
cuando hay personas como carlita que
que hay noches que con 75 centavos se
alimentan 6 personas o nos quejamos
porque no podemos ir a la playa cuando
hay personas que tienen que caminar
todos los días 30 minutos para poder ir
a traer agua y para poder
de repente depender para sus necesidades
pero también me daba esperanza me da
esperanza por carlita porque contrario a
lo que nosotros podemos pensar ella y de
su vida con mucha alegría y de su vida
tranquila y de su vida bien y lo que yo
pensaba es carlita es muchísimo más
feliz que la mayoría de las personas que
conozco
es precisamente como los de carlita en
el salvador hay muchos de acuerdo a la
encuesta de hogares y propósitos
múltiples en el salvador el 45% de las
personas vienen alguna condición de
pobreza yo siempre he sido una persona
super soñadora y cuando mirada estas
cifras me preguntaba dónde están los
sueños de estos 45 por ciento de
personas y cada vez que conversó con
ellos precisamente decía yo sé que los
sueños están ahí pero a veces lo ven
como utopías lo ven como inalcanzable
les pregunto a los niños ya las niñas
cuando tengo el placer de poder hacerles
entrevistas y muchos de ellos dicen yo
sueño con ser policía sueño con ser
secretaria con terminar mi escuela pero
lo ven a veces bien lejos hoy
precisamente vamos a hablar de este
proceso de construcción de sueños y por
qué es necesario de que además de soñar
también los que construyamos para que
podamos apoyar a niños como carlita
primero es súper importante saber qué
significa esto de la deconstrucción de
acuerdo a la real academia de la lengua
española deconstruir significa deshacer
analíticamente algo para
la nueva estructura y precisamente como
les contaba al ser una persona super
soñadora un tiempo en que me detuve a
pensar y dije qué está pasando con tus
sueños y empecé el proceso de
construcción de mis sueños y para mí
este proceso ha tenido tres momentos
súper importantes el primero es cuando
me uní al movimiento scout hace 15 años
escuché por primera vez el lema siempre
listos para servir la primera vez que
los escuché y que había un par de
personas corriendo como una pañoleta en
el cuello yo dije esta gente de verdad
está bien loca jamás pensé que un
movimiento me iba a cambiar tanto la
vida en un principio del movimiento
scout cuando estaba en mi adolescencia
me enseñó mucho y me iba dando cuenta de
esta realidad del salvador que yo miraba
tan lejos pero el movimiento scout me la
iba acercando después y la parte más
gratificante para mí ha sido cuando ya
pasé a ser dirigente y ha sido lo más
gratificante porque día a día puedo ver
el proceso de jóvenes que tienen unas
ganas y un anhelo de cambiar el mundo
y de cumplir precisamente la misión que
nuestro fundador baden powell nos dejó
que es dejar el mundo en mejores
condiciones de cómo lo encontramos pero
precisamente que lo que como dirigentes
o consejeros nosotros enseñamos a los
chicos en el movimiento scout es que
nosotros no podemos pretender cambiar el
mundo si no nos conocemos porque este
proceso de querer hacer un cambio real
en la sociedad empieza por auto
conocernos por autoevaluarnos por saber
precisamente quiénes somos porque solo
sabiendo que ya no somos nosotros es
como podemos decir ok ya sé que tengo y
es así como pueden en realidad dejar el
mundo en mejores condiciones de cómo lo
encontramos el movimiento scout a mí me
ayudó para hacerme la pregunta de qué
estás soñando y me di cuenta que en
aquel momento mi sueño era irme del país
soñado cómo obtener una beca soñaba con
tener un trabajo súper grande en un
lugar súper reconocido pero en ningún
momento soñaba o personas como carlita
entraban en ese panorama
el segundo proceso de mi deconstrucción
de sueños fue cuando empecé a trabajar
en una organización que busca y aborda
las causas fundamentales de la pobreza y
la violencia a través de programas de
educación y salud mi trabajo me acerca
día a día a historias como la de carlita
y tenemos el honor de estar junto a un
equipo de colaboradores que están ahí
luchando día a día por construir una
mejor sociedad también mi trabajo me
ayudó y me acerco a este panorama que yo
digo que es como que en el salvador
tenemos dos países en uno porque por un
lado estamos los eternos desagradecida
los que nos quejamos por todo pero por
otro lado hay gente que quiere salir
adelante que incluye a niñas como karl y
está en sus sueños y que dicen saben yo
no me puedo quedar con los brazos
cruzados vemos a voluntarios vemos al
mismo está todos los días trabajando por
construir un mejor futuro y de eso
precisamente es lo que se trata la
deconstrucción de sueños como yo bien
les comentaba el proceso de
deconstrucción de sueños hubo una
segunda pregunta súper importante
qué estás soñando y para quién estás
soñando en ese momento me di cuenta
justamente cuando estaba en esta
organización que yo estaba soñando solo
para mí soñaba con hacerme súper grande
soñado con tener una posición pero el
centro de mis sueños era yo y no es que
esté mal lo que está mal es que solo sea
yo y no esté nadie más a mi lado
el tercer proceso de la deconstrucción
de sueños y precisamente fue cuando el
año pasado tuve la oportunidad de
trabajar y de participar en un programa
que se llama global sports mentoring
program 10 sentí ahí tuve la oportunidad
de conocer a 15 mujeres de 14 países de
todo el mundo de diferentes panoramas y
aprendí que todos los países tenemos
retos diferentes si nosotros pensamos el
salvador tiene un montón de retos por
supuesto pero todos los países los
tienen igual pero una cosa que aprendí
en día sentí es que siempre tenemos que
luchar por inspirar a alguien más y
porque nuestros sueños incluyan a
alguien más porque precisamente nosotros
no estamos para vivir nuestra vida solo
para cumplir nuestros sueños enviasen ti
también aprendí que tenemos que confiar
en el proceso porque el proceso
precisamente se da paso a paso nosotros
no podemos pretender que las cosas van a
cambiar de la noche a la mañana y eso
era lo que nos repetían mucho y sentí
confíen en el proceso y eso es confiar
en el proceso de construcción de sueños
es saber que yo no puedo
pretender que de hoy para mañana mi
sueño va a empezar a ser diferente o que
de hoy hasta mañana el país va a ser
totalmente diferente porque tenemos que
confiar en que todos estamos en un
proceso vamos a hacer historias cómo se
habilita a mí me llenan de mucha
esperanza precisamente porque es una
niña que definitivamente vienen muchos
retos pero lo que mismo me encanta
resaltar es esta parte donde ella
incluso sigue diciendo yo quiero ayudar
a más personas y ese es el ejemplo que
todos tenemos que seguir definitivamente
que para hacer que los sueños de las
demás personas se cumplan nosotros
tenemos que construir para ayudar que
las demás personas cumplan sus sueños
nosotros tenemos que ponernos a pensar
que estás soñando y para quién estás
soñando
karlita es una de las más de 4.000 niñas
que participan en el club de niñas y ahí
estamos nosotros
forjando diferentes niñas y ciudadanas
pero precisamente lo más importante es
que para todas estas niñas niños o que
en general cualquier persona del
salvador pueda tener el derecho a soñar
como todas ellas me tienen y como
nosotros mismos
se hace porque otras personas han tenido
también el deseo de dejar de soñar
egoístamente de dejar de soñar solo para
ellos y empezaron a incluir a niñas como
cáritas en sus sueños porque al final de
eso se trata la deconstrucción de sueños
no es más que la deconstrucción de
nuestra propia realidad es sentarnos y
pensar en que estamos parados en donde
estamos para que nosotros así podamos
saber cómo podemos apoyar a los demás
porque precisamente no se trata solo de
pensar en nosotros y a nosotros los
jóvenes nos dicen un montón de veces
esta frase tenés derecho a soñar y
definitivamente que la tenemos estamos
en todo el derecho de soñar pero yo creo
que como jóvenes también tenemos el
deber de soñar no solo por nosotros
mismos sino soñar e incluir a niños como
carlita o cualquier otra persona que los
inspiren para que los sueños de ellos
también se hagan realidad y para que
juntos podamos construir una mejor
sociedad muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
muchísimas gracias mercedes por tan
interesante charla yo creo que bien
importante que nosotros como juventudes
nos pongamos a pensar no estamos
construyendo nuestros sueños estamos
alcanzando los sueños de alguien más los
estamos empoderando como tex colonia
miramonte estamos muy agradecidos de
haberla tenido como con nosotros y pues
bueno existe una frase siempre estamos
re comenzando a vivir y que bien retomar
nuestros sueños y de construirlos a
diario pues bueno les recordamos a
nuestro público que pueden hacer todas
las preguntas a través de las redes
sociales y tenemos tres la primera es
mercy que es recomendación le daría a
todas las personas para empezar a
deconstruir sus sueños yo creo que es
súper importante como en primer lugar es
que pensemos que estamos soñando porque
eso fue precisamente el primer choque de
realidad que yo tuve darme cuenta que
mis sueños estaban siendo para
engrandecer me a mí y no de repente para
que el salvador pudiera mejorar entonces
ese es el primer paso preguntarnos que
estamos soñando y como segundo paso
obligado también es saber para quién
estamos soñando
sí sí de repente en nuestros sueños
somos nosotros los únicos los que
estamos al centro o podemos apoyar que
la vida de alguien más sea mejor ok ya
saben entonces todos a preguntarnos
también que estamos soñando para quien
estamos soñando nuestra segunda pregunta
es que hace día a día o como evalúa si
usted está construyendo sus sueños a
diario
esa es una pregunta bien difícil porque
la deconstrucción de sueños
definitivamente que es un proceso a
diario y un proceso que me pregunto es
siempre estás teniendo los pies en el
piso estás en realidad cambiando la vida
de alguien más o ayudando porque de
repente no somos nosotros los que solos
vamos a cambiar la vida de alguien más
sino que se trata de venir y verificar
qué hacer siempre una buena acción que
eso es precisamente algo que va en poder
el fundador del movimiento scout nos
dijo a todos los scouts del mundo hacer
siempre una buena acción diaria entonces
el proceso de construcción de sueño yo
creo que es precisamente eso hacer una
buena acción diaria a saber si estoy
teniendo los pies realmente en la tierra
y si estoy soñando no solo para mí no
solo egoístamente aquí perfecto
muchísimas gracias mercy a todo el
equipo que se encuentra aquí un aplauso
para ella